five men accused of helping the 9 11
hijackers are due in a military court
today for the first time in a year and a
half the hearing in guantanamo bay cuba
comes near the 20th anniversary of the
terror attacks that killed nearly 3
thousand americans senior investigative
correspondent catherine herridge is in
cuba at guantanamo bay for us catherine
good morning to you what's behind all
these delays
tony the lawyers are still arguing over
the evidence and there is no date on the
calendar for the actual trial to begin
this pretrial hearing is the first time
the five defendants have gone to the
high security court since february last
year the latest judge on the case
retired and then the pandemic hit the
five defendants including the
self-described architect of the attack
khalid sheikh mohammed are accused of
war crimes among them conspiring to
commit acts of terrorism hijacking and
the intentional murder of civilians the
biggest legal bloc is the continued
secrecy surrounding the men's detention
before they got to guantanamo after 9 11
they were captured and held in cia
secret prisons where they were subjected
to interrogation tactics that critics
call torture including waterboarding and
sleep deprivation to this day much of
the evidence is off limits to the
defense these delays have gone on for so
long that i know some 911 family members
who have traveled to guantanamo to see
the defendants in court and have since
died never seeing justice in their
lifetime nate
catherine thank you so much